herrliches tor xii wir haben immer noch
genannt das würde ich eine politik
machen zum einen einsamen kampf gesehen
so einsam gespielt am anfang dieses
filmes steht jede größte niederlage
durch nationalrätin badran ist immerhin
schon vier mal fast gestorben
david die sozialdemokraten auch diesmal
wieder einen weg zurück ins leben finden
also wieder boden unter die füße
bekommen
minute
[Musik]
diese film geht jacqueline badran nach
um diese film geht der frage nach warum
sich eine rote politikerin grün und blau
ärgert wenn es um grund und boden geht
so zogen reis frage braucht sie nur
wieder politische botschaft einzige
chance muss das volk und die
grundschrift zu sagen experten
der capitano memorial und tschechiens
das wasser sie mit dem teuren darauf
unter wie wir briten zurück dorthin wo
die niederlage stattfand apps 2014
jacqueline badran am eingang zum
ständerat für sie ist dass die pforten
der hölle
als nationalrätin darf sie hier nur zu
hören
max kohr bedeutet das grund und boden in
der schweiz nun kaufen kann
wer in der schweiz wohnt oder
geschäftssitz hat also schweizer und
ausländer die hier steuern bezahlen
dagegen machte die immobilien lobbydruck
das gesetz sollte abgeschafft werden
aber daran konnte national und ständerat
überzeugen
die lex koller zu retten doch das war
ihm nicht genug daran wollte eine
verschärfung bundesrat und nationalrat
stimmt ihm zu
die letzte hörte der ständerat die linke
wartet auf ihren rechten gegenspieler
denn inzwischen zurückgetretenen
ständerat georges theiler der vertreter
der immobilienbranche argumentiert mit
dem bauboom
warum haben wir dieses hoch wir haben es
weil die nachfrage sehr hoch ist das
muss man einfach mal erkennen die
nachfrage ist deshalb hoch weil wir alle
mehr wohnraum wollen wir wollen ein
eigenheim wir wollen eine größere
wohnung auch die mieterinnen und mieter
wollen größere wohnungen schönere
wohnungen das ist ja unser recht es geht
uns ja gut aber sind daran jetzt die
ausländischen investoren schuld ja wohl
kaum
es ist eine tatsache ich glaube das
wurde heute auch nicht bestritten dass
heute immobilien von der reinen
wertanlage zur ertrags anlage geworden
sind und zwar zu sehr attraktiven
investitionen das zeigt sich daran dass
milliarden milliarden von franken aus
den aktienmärkten in den immobilienmarkt
geschlossen sind und aufgrund dieser
analyse hat man mit der lex koller
entschieden
der erwerb von wohnimmobilien an den
steuersatz zu binden und übrigens nicht
und ich denke es ist wichtig dass wir
das wieder in erinnerung rufen nicht an
den pass zu binden sondern an den
streubesitz also ich bitte sie reden sie
diese beiden
emotionen ab auch jene die trüben schon
im entstehen die das gegenteil wollen
und bleiben sie irgendwo auf einem
rechtlich klaren weg für alle weil ich
ja in der schweiz investieren wollen die
einheimischen und die ausländischen
firmen damit sind wir ja definitiv
entscheidungsreif wir stimmen ab
sie haben sich mit 26 gegen 16 stimmen
bei 9 enthaltungen für die ablehnung
betreibt die krönung ihrer bisherigen
politischen laufbahn versagt begonnen
hat sie in der politischen opposition
politisiert durch die jugendunruhen der
80er jahre wie sie damals im chor mit
den quoten macht aus dem staat
gurkensalat und hütten sie
foto politik kommen statt
teilen und jede linke irgendwo serie
freiheit leben
der anarchische teilnehmen haben also
ihre staatskritischen tradition richtig
ausgeprägt
ich finde der staatengemeinschaft und
dass man gemeinschaftlich eigenen
einfluss nimmt auf dem stand absolut
wichtig dass maxi net wenn man ihnen
vorwirft ja von eurem tagen zieht sich
neben tote gezählt wer zum beispiel das
turnier steigt hörte sorgen ich bitte da
nicht mehr so wie in der ersten reihe
und radstand hat dass das passiert ist
und funktioniert außerdem besuchten
titulieren war dann irgendwie
bedrohungen sogar wurde sie hinter sich
sehr speziell
der firmensitz von jacqueline badran am
stauffacher platz hat sie eine
liegenschaft der stadt zürich gemietet
seit 15 jahren betreibt sie eine
computerfirma die sozialdemokratin ist
boss über 30
die spezialisten der tiefste lohn im
verhältnis zum höchsten also zum lohn
vom badran ist eins zu 1,6 komplexe
websites mit komplexer software aber
alles nur der teil und geht also darum
es halt frontend das die user oder
anregen wird das alles von der
konzeption mit dank und vor allem sehr
viele termine bis hin zum programmierer
zum frontend was man nicht alles was ich
aufgewachsen ist sie in australien
der libanesische vater war dort
textilunternehmer die mutter stammt aus
zürich daran studierte biologie und
ökologie und arbeitete jahrelang in der
kantonalen verwaltung als studentin
verdingte sich jacqueline badran als
skilehrerin jacqueline ist ein
glückspilz
als kind ist sie beinahe ertrunken dann
aus dem fünften stock eines hauses
gefallen und später auch noch von einer
schneelawine begraben wurden
das unglaublichste aber passierte ihr
bei einer geschäftsreise badran stürzte
mit dem flugzeug ab
im november 2001 starben 24 passagiere
beim anflug auf den zürcher flughafen
daran kommt mit leichten verletzungen
aus den trümmern
aus diesen teilen hat ein freund kunst
gemacht habe da mal glücklich kann jetzt
alles anders für mich dass ich mir so
eine cd maxi sich träge glücklich sie
privilegiert ich dafür gerade die sich
so privilegiert und die räume für das
gehör kompensiert und so eine 16 termine
jugend rücken kompensiert wie einzigen
das kompensiert jetzt hier womöglich
kann im laden das im philly die hunde
denen bisher schulden bislang ist das
ex-model sind karg 16 mal überlebt
werden nicht überleben
da muss man irgendwie er bisher freiere
dazu gemacht wie gedanken ich bin nach
dem flugzeugabsturz zum beispiel wo bis
vor mit ni und dann intervention also
glaube das hätte das extra gemacht hat
und dass ich dann schon gedanken aber
irgendein mann finde verantworten
biologie und evolution
jacqueline badran zieht erneut auf ein
schlachtfeld hinauf nach morgarten
ebenso gut wie die svp-vertreter
beherrscht sie den populismus und bemüht
bei bedarf die schweizer mythen als
linke wie sie den konservativen dieses
schlachtfeld nicht allein überlassen
wichtige grün für die schlachten sie im
boden nutze es steht zwischen dem
schweizer und zwar zwischen der
kooperation schweiz und dem umland und
im wesentlichen ist das ein zahmer
braucht sie zwischen zwei prinzipien sei
das prinzip von gemeinnütziger boden
nötig womit dem nutzer von bode also
sechs volt oder viehzucht auf
teilzeitbasis eigentlichen klerikal
bodennutzung prinzip und das ist
realistisch migros und sodann der note 7
uhr am stadtrand folgt oder gar nicht
und was lehrt russ der schlacht am
morgarten wofür sie bewundert ja auch
passiert ich politik führe die kleine
ziege wohnbau um ihr album zu hören über
von ganz rechts tecdax minister die
prinzipien importieren und das ist also
absurd wenn das ich wirklich also
urschweizer ist das ist der fundamentale
staatsverständnis vermieters über und
die duschen zu ihnen und dass ich
eigentlich dass man sich auch zeigen was
hat jetzt auch noch das ist
erfolgsmodell schweiz ein buch über die
genauso mit der kooperation bestätigt
kathrin diesen umgang der alten
eidgenossen mit grund und boden
beim begriff zeitgenossen sie gerne auf
das wort genossen
bei uns ist die immobiliengesellschaft
dir geht sieht mir zwei typische völlig
neues phänomen und die rechte
verteidiger das eigentlich also sie sind
ja ich die moderne land effekt wenn man
sowas peter goldmacher und eine haube zu
kommen denen eigentlich die anti auf sky
hat quasi jeden monat immer wieder die
war informiert die reform vor der hüttn
eigentums krise und machte druck
da sich bei trans aktuell und morgarten
züri west ein quartier am stadtrand
denen erlaubt der hochbau und ganze hört
es nötig also mit der viele betroffen
das hat der eigentümer namensrechte
mobimo der hunderte von millionen vor
sogenannten planungen leistungsfrei
blahniks grün und infrastruktur können
beschert und die öffentliche hand hat
erfolg da natürlich unglaublich viel
investiert zum beispiel als städtische
geld 50 millionen fürs traum vorstellen
wo man denkt es eine wunderbar in vier
minuten habe mit dem traum der druck den
die wähler bruck mit dem o2 oder wie ton
was ist mit all i wanna architektur
das hat unsere 240 millionen kostet 40
millionen franken das macht dass man da
die honige natürlich optimierte oder
führer vereinfachen und da das ist
städtisch land und da jetzt ein park für
14 millionen der zahlen die eigentümer
bis 3,0 millionen aber von der stadt
zürich kostet das 3,8 millionen jährlich
wiederkehrend die unterhalts- und
kapitalkosten und das ist nicht anders
eine subvention für dieses hochhaus hat
die immobilienfirma von ständerat einer
gebaut wir wollten ihn mit baggern
konfrontieren teilen aber hat
ausgeschlagen dass ähnliche differenzen
will er nicht in der öffentlichkeit
ausfechten um politisch habe ohnehin
gewonnen
das firma vom hersteller hat wieder
verwaltung gestellt wie die zweite sieg
das mit lex koller aufweicht und
auslandes spekulative immer wieder
kapital hat sowie die neue schleuse die
schweiz trüben nachdem das legitimiert
worden ist der verteiler mit dem mobimo
börse hat natürlich zu wenn sagt spürt
mag ich ihn gerne als privatperson aber
als politiker nicht das inakzeptabel
neben dem mondänen züri west liegt das
industriequartier mittendrin die josef
wiese die günstige genossenschaft
siedlung ist begehrt als patron noch im
zürcher gemeinderat politisiert brachte
sie ein gesetz zur förderung der
genossenschaften durch bis 2030 soll der
anteil und genossenschaftswohnungen in
der stadt zürich auf 33 prozent
ansteigen
dem thema genossenschaften wohnungsbau
und bodenspekulation ist sie auch im
nationalrat treu geblieben
das kann man nur machen weil 30
angestellte in dieser zeit für sie
arbeiten im rahmen der frühlingssession
2015 wird die parlamentarier us
meisterschaft ausgetragen
badran spielt absichtlich mit
französischen karten damit sie ja nicht
mit ihrem widersacher ständerat an
denselben tisch muss teil spielt mit
deutschen kranken an sich ein wenig um
nach meinungen zu baggern gibt es die
begeisterung schwüle der genossen eher
langweilig dann den respekt der gegner
für babbels faktentreue schon etwas
bemerkenswert
nein nicht besserwisserisch zivil sehr
einfach vieles besser aber keine
berichteten von gleichen in bad rans
kehl
ihr ruppiges stil und die schlechte
angewohnheit ohne verabschiedung aus
einer versammlung abzuhauen missfällt
wenn das aber der gipfel ihre
fehlbarkeit ist verzichten wir auf eine
umfrage mit dem mikrofon
so schön
wir haben mit geschmack
[Musik]
ich weiß es nicht mitgekriegt
das ist politische karriere habe ich
irgendwie
was und wen lässt die rote kämpferin
neben sich noch gelten wie sie ständiger
teile aus teilt ist grenzwertig damit
begibt sich byrne auf krieges parkett
[Musik]
nach der session ein wochenende
skifahren mit e mann victor er arbeitet
das buch hauten und velokurier weiteres
ziel liegt im nebel mürren im berner
oberland
das altehrwürdige hotel regina in die
schlagzeilen geraten vor zwei jahren
russen und chinesen fuhr mit koffer voll
geld ein
daran will wissen wie es dann aber einer
genossenschaft gelang dem ausländischen
kapital die stirn zu bieten
die russen wollten nämlich das hotel
aushöhlen und zweitwohnungen bauen in
gewinn hätten sie nicht in der schweiz
versteuert
ehemalige stammgäste betreiben heute das
hotel regina als familien und kultur
hotel das ist so eine spezielle set der
logen stehend das hätte sähe das anders
aus
und das lohnt sagt engagiere und somit
die gruppe samt seiner gebracht und ins
probieren muss so hoch liegt aber unter
geister witzleben also wir können also
23 russ wechselt zum tsv unterlag für
mode also ein svp grenzpolitik notabene
im auftrag des rückkaufs der reime und
gehen genauso hier offenfahren ostern
das imposante und mehr glücklich wie
sich das unbedingt machen und dank dem
handy interessant aber nurmehr
herzklinik können einfach so zur schau
zu stellen hat der probanden
zweitrangigen und und eigentums monika
denn die meisten heute wo natürlich so
viel verkauft
designer was bank wirklich funktioniert
von kathrin kurven sich gegenseitig auf
die schulter
das beispiel mit dem hotel regina macht
ihnen mut es doch nur wieder eine
volksinitiative für eine verschärfung
der rics kohle zu probieren
das hat so eine touristin skifahrer auch
im nebel wittert sie morgenröte
und obwohl so steiner nicht mehr im
ständerat ist die gegner werden
jacqueline badran nicht ausgehen
[Musik]